india is in the grip of a health
emergency with record numbers of covid
cases the country has been put on the
uk's red list and visitors will be
banned from entering britain from friday
earlier the education secretary told us
the government has to remain vigilant
against new variants well let's talk to
our reporter neville lazarus who's in
new delhi for us
this morning just how serious a
situation is it for
i mean not only people living in new
jersey but the the health workers the
the hospitals there what sort of
pressure are they under
it is absolutely stressful for the
health services
at the moment not only in the capital
here but across
the country we've seen beds have run out
at hospitals ventilators even medicine
and also
oxygen the chief minister of the state
of delhi
had had warned of acute shortage of
of oxygen at hospitals and this is we're
talking about a capital
this is because india has one of the
highest
daily case loads in the world in the
last 24 hours
260 000 new cases were added 1760 people
had died in 24 hours
so these are huge numbers in the last
two weeks two and a half million
new cases have been added to india's
tally making it the second world
second worst country in the world uh but
it wasn't
unexpected that britain would put india
on the red list
but this is what the world health
organization
a special envoy of kovit 19 dr david
navarro
had to say although you believe
that if you put a sort of very strong
border control
in you can somehow keep out variants
all the experience over the years is
that
yes you can slow down the arrival of
new diseases through what you do at your
borders but you can never stop it
completely
and that's exactly what happened india
had one of the severest lockdowns
anywhere in the world last year and now
we're seeing these explosive numbers
particularly the government is
struggling they haven't handled the
covet situation in india at the moment
the prime minister
and his cabinet have been busy uh in
election campaigning because there have
been state elections
hundreds and thousands of people are
are at his rallies and at roadshows
there's been a big hindu festival where
about 50 million people
will be converging in this month and so
these super spreaders have
precipitated this whole mat out and
everyone is struggling